in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape let's say hello
to professor BAM Thank You gunk an
expert on anti-aging medicine welcome
professor - in good shape
hello it's a recipe for a long and
healthy life
well there's no such thing as the magic
pill for eternal youth but there's a lot
of things we can do for healthy aging
because we understood aging more or less
on a molecular level we knows the
biological mechanisms and you know once
you know how things work then you can
try to influence them but how much is in
our genes around 30% there are twin
studies that have proved that quite well
and that means that even if you have bad
genes because you were not so lucky with
changing the right parents you still
have something like 70% to make up for
those bad dreams by lifestyle by
nutrition by sports exercise and so on
so how exactly do we make up for our bad
genes and so how what can I personally
do well first of all it's all those
things that our grandma already told us
that is don't go fat don't grow fat
exercise eat your veggies stop smoking
all these things I mean it's quite banal
but it's still more or less the basis of
anti-aging medicine and then on top of
course you can do more that is hormone
replacement therapy that is taking
certain supplements that is maybe even
talking taking drugs like low-dose
aspirin and so on and and what can I do
without going to the doctor is it
important for me to stay on the go to
exercise go on exercise exercise and
sports is something like the universal
preventive medicine we know that sport
helps to prevent cardiovascular disease
we know it helps to prevent osteoporosis
even prevents Alzheimer disease dementia
so yes next to good nutrition exercise
is the main thing and what about the
good nutrition are they special foods I
should really go for like the super
foods yeah there are foods but I think
this is a world wide TV shows so and
there are different spots on the on the
earth where there is very nutritional
food that is for example in the
Mediterranean area that is also in Asia
and so on so it's it's mainly really our
fruits and vegetables which contain a
lot of antioxidants and
anti-inflammatory substances so stick to
this keep away from fast food yeah and
is it is it wise to choose from nature
like eating an apple or is it better to
go into a pharmacy and grab some pills
for supplements the Apple is definitely
the better solution because an apple
does not just contain 12 vitamins as a
multivitamin pill but it contains a lot
of other substances there are thirty to
fifty thousand secondary plant
substances that are important and it's
also the matrix in which they are
embedded that is important so definitely
five a day fruit or vegetables is better
than a multivitamin bill what about
stress and stress relief our viewers
several gana Stan from India wants to
know if yoga and meditation may help you
in Aging yes it may help because there
are things that keep you young there are
also things that make you getting old
quickly and stress is one of them even
from the point of hormones there's a
stress hormone called cortisol and we
know that high cortisol level are really
pro aging hormones so to lower them
something like you guys okay
meditation is okay you know coming down
even if you have an iPhone it has to you
know recharge its batteries and same is
true for us the right choice
testosterone replacement therapy when
would you advise patients to get
testosterone treatment well first of all
there should be some complaints night
sweats depression loss of libido and
then there should be a lab test that
really shows that the
testosterone deficiency is the cause of
these complaints and then formal
replacement therapy with androgens makes
sense so any both the complaints and the
test results and if you don't want to
see your doctor and still want to boost
your testosterone levels perhaps by
natural means so can you boost it by
yourself without taking in drugs there
are two main methods the one is exercise
again mainly muscle building second is
reduce your body weight cut down on your
fatty tissue because in the fatty tissue
there is a certain enzyme on the
aromatase and this is metabolizing
testosterone into estrogen so especially
with elder men who have little
testosterone and they go overweight then
they have the little testosterone that
they still have metabolized into
estrogens and then they really get into
hormone deficiency estrogens is not
really good for men it's better for
women because it's sexual home means to
need some estrogens but too much of
course is not what men want okay so
let's talk about women there's a lot of
discussion going on about hormone
replacement therapy in women is this an
anti-aging method
yeah the discussion indeed was very
controversial especially in the
beginning of the new millennium there
were some studies from the United States
whi that showed that hormone replacement
therapy is leading to higher risk of
breast cancer trombonist and so on and
since then we have learned a lot and we
have changed a little bit the regime we
now work more with my identical hormones
we prefer to give estrogen the
transdermal way and was this it has
become safe and it has become again an
anti-aging medicine and transdermal
means with patches and with Chris Petrus
or Jay Elias and this is safer than just
giving pills yes definitely it is
reducing the risk of breast cancer it's
reducing the risk of thrombosis and
those were the main two risks of hormone
replacement and it doesn't make women
look great is it good for the skin too
it does yes estrogens have effects on
many parts of the body and skin and
mucous membranes are part of it
so definitely
estrogens are also the hormones of
beauty so what's on the horizon of
anti-aging medicine what can we expect
in the next 10 years saying there are
there are different scenarios the one
scenario is that we are shifting from
preventive medicine to regenerative
medicine so we have for example stem
cells that is you know one of the big
visions of anti-aging medicine that one
day we are able to regenerate cells
tissues and so on then there is a well I
might say a radical line in anti-aging
medicine called radical life extension
operated grey is one of the spokesmen
and they say armed healthy aging is not
enough we want ending aging or so for
example living forever yeah living
forever I mean things will it come the
other one is is it really desirable I
mean long eternity is a mighty long time
especially towards the end could be
desirable if you stay healthy on the way
so and you try to do that everybody's
staying healthy innovations thank you
thank you for being with us in the
studio it's a garage revolt and be
healthy thank you